welcome to this video for round 11
coverage of the candidates and this is
some about the game swidler playing
white against aronia and playing black
two of the players who still have not
great chances but at least theoretical
chances to catch the tournament leader
vishy anand but yeah they suddenly need
a win somewhere let's see what happened
in this game my deaf three plate yes
with less varying his openings I guess
he didn't like so much to play efore
here as a Roman is a well-known e5
expert not quite sure what line he would
have gone for but yeah can only
speculate aronian played d5 and g3 this
actually was to be expected sir Lance
played quite a bit of those flank
openings recently and yeah well I'm
playing this kind of openings myself so
I can share some some knowledge in the
next couple of moves played the Bishop
g4 yeah this is what Aronian had played
in fact before in last year's candidates
tournament against chronic it's one of
the one of the most reliable lines to
play against this g3 opening it's a very
much comparable to tour to a queen pawn
opening from the white side just with
reversed colors like the tory attack or
sometimes the trump off steam Rotom
pawelski not sure how to pronounce that
um Bishop g2 of course need to cover the
night don't want double pawns and now
aronian played the movie 6 in this
position they're already some I mean
here there are already some move order
um tricks and subtleties that black
needs to be aware of the six is a very
flexible and solid move which is hard to
do without it in the long run and
making it now has a very young very
concrete idea you don't want to commit
your nights yet and we'll see a that
this sum is this plays a role c4 and c6
yeah um they're also a possibility is to
play differently here of course you can
play 97 for example i'm just going to
show you some alternatives this however
allows this exchange the exchange force
from seaport of C porn against a porn
and this structure in recent years has
gained some popularity which to be
honest does not surprise me at all I I
end the number of some friends of mine
clubmates in fact have played this
structure for for quite a number of
years and found it to be very
interesting to play in the long run as
wide as getting to central pawns against
one and also very often if you just
consider the porn structure i'm just
going to put put put some moves on the
boards it's about this structure the
structure it maybe does not look like
much at first sight but in the long run
this can be a quite a promising way to
fight providers you very often get to
move your night and play f4 at some
stage and then you have four against
three on the King side that you can
actually push ahead it's a quite an
interesting a set up that white really
much likes to play and our own Ian's
setup is very much directed against that
idea and we see why just very soon plate
see success mentioned and now in this
position swidler captured and here we
see the idea that black set up in fact
contains aronian captured on a three
first takes here and then he takes with
the sea porn
of course why the capture if you take
now with the sea ponder this fundamental
trick so you need to take first and then
recapture with the sea porn this was
blacks idea you play the pawn moves
first and get in this exchange on a
three so that you now are able to set up
your nights on c6 and on f6 and this is
why he also hadn't played 90 d 7 early
which you can do it's not a bad line but
it does not allow like to set up exactly
a position like kilogram on the bourne
now in fact my personal belief is
looking at the the move order sup
leticia that white shouldn't take on d5
here it mean it's a well at line its
cost about fifty percent even but I
believe that this is so solid for black
that white should do something else I
personally prefer to castle here hoping
that black place 97 so we get back into
the CD five lines and something like
that is personally my choice trying to
keep a bit more tension in the position
always hoping for this structure to
arrive not that it is winning or
anything but it's it's the aim that why
this is hoping for something like this
is what black golf does note that again
this can easily happen with an almost a
transposition to the game okay but this
was played and now we see what I meant
black puts its pieces on the most
natural squares here here actually is
there is an alternative for white white
can also go with d3 here this is in fact
the recommendation of the leaf of the
well-known Romanian theoretician Mahama
een Michael Maron as some people
pronounce it which sounds totally wrong
for a Romanian name but I'm probably
screwing it up as well
this is alternative but well okay the
idea is obviously to go E for at some
point must simply be more flexible in
the center yeah well swing up lady for
which is also fine and here we come to a
position that was actually seen in last
year's candidates tournament between
chrome neck playing wide and aronian
like so the position that could be
anticipated in fact in the in the press
conference Aronian said that he had
actually prepared prepared a different
answer to Knight f3 g3 but accidentally
just out of routine played the same line
again it sometimes happens to you really
I have this experience myself you follow
think okay I'll play that for a change
and then sort out of habit you you play
a two or three moves that you usually do
and then wait I cannot really do that
anymore what I intended to do so he got
into the same position again yeah in
this game against chrome Nick which
actually led to a position where chrome
Nick had had very good winning chances
um he played queen bee eight aronia this
is actually a somewhat ambitious move
I'll quickly show what happened in this
game him and now he played b5 which
after efore let two were very really
complicated to struggle the point was
that the moose before could be answered
by Bishop f4 Queen B 6 9 a-4 and later
white goading me five which really
complicated middle game in the game here
after day we played Queen 27 which is
the more solid choice I would say yeah
let's look at this structure from a
general point of view what exactly are
the plans for both sides yeah this is
this is the problem that I personally
have with this position when I
looked at this line as a white player I
like to play this 93g three setups but
this line is one of the lines that I
dislike most because I simply feel that
why it has very little to play form
you've got this somewhat close center
and then what exactly are the ideas that
you can play with yeah white has the
idea to play efore at some point not
difficult or not easy to do as black
always has this pressure against the
form so I mean just for simply this is
not working and even with preparation
it's not so easy to to get get in um
yeah and what else is there you can
expand on the queenside but that's it
basically you don't really have much in
terms of altering the pawn structure
it's just a very symmetrical yeah and
what can like do to be honest for
blanket it's almost the same you really
cannot do much in an ideal scenario you
might get to a position where you have
half nights in a closed position against
this bishop which has a slight tendency
to become a bad piece if you play it not
to accurately with white but other than
that it's very difficult for black you
can very often is has a position in
terms of prospects if you check the palm
brakes and black for black it's the same
I mean how you can you ever play e52
weakening d 5 e 5 is tough and what what
other break do you have in the position
it's basically none the Aronian the
chronic aronia gave only got really
sharp because i only had pushed b5 early
and he is not doing that and we have
from a very slow build-up 98 is actually
moved that i like he's putting the night
on d6 where it looks at this important c
foursquare nights are very useful in
this position it's really not a big
problem that white has got the bishop am
at least for the time being the bishop
pair can be
term factor but as mentioned it is very
difficult to see any site making a big
progress yeah this is very normal this
kind of regrouping white prepares a
possible doubling on the C file and
maybe expand with the pawns black set up
here is really nice he's making the
pieces you're perfectly placed to
counter um via white advances if you
look at a four-year for example which
would be a way at least two to go
forward then like simply takes and no
matter how white takes it it's the same
you will put a knight on d5 that this is
197 was played and next there will be a
bishop here or bishop to have six and
this is just a very nice blockade white
has the bishops but the bishop only one
is not expect or not especially great i
mean it is it is not great on e 1 that's
quite clear but also cannot be easily
improved so he form is leading nowhere
he played a b3 and try to do something
on the queenside putting pieces here and
black just dropped back to the ATM the
d6 night was also nicely covering the
porn on on b7 yeah yes video i decided
to do a little bit p prepare this
advance on the queenside 96 and even
before you always must be a bit cautious
about these moves like be form as c4 is
weakened however it seems that 94 which
looks tempting it's maybe a bit tricky
for black here what can it play this
exchange sacrifice and go be five and
we'll get b7 I don't really think that
blackshot dumb should allow that you can
try to make it work with let's say
counter sacrifice on c5 and stuff but
it's not it's not really attractive
position so aronian avoided that night
to be eight yeah that's not a passive
move really it is intending to play b6
at the right moment and cover stay six
square yeah be five plate and in this
position instead of b5 silly I could
have tried a form would have been an
interesting tribe but I think like can
equalize with Knight takes e4 seems to
be the most precise way to play
something like that yeah this should be
far as in a for hanging I just
recognized that hmm now that's it's
simply not much I mean black can can
always play at the end of those lines 97
to have six and to be okay besides a for
singing yeah well he didn't play your
form he played there be fire first and
here we've come to an interesting point
in this game actually there to be honest
the only really interesting point here
aronian played Bishop d7 which seems to
be an inner carruth surprisingly enough
97 was just keeping the game within
completely equal territory very hard to
imagine how wide can avoid further
exchanges on the see how Bishop e7 looks
perfectly normal but it has a slight
drawback here sweet Allah actually could
have played a form and this seems to be
a bit this is what he played before um
seems to be a bit tricky for black he
needs to be aware of various things and
there's a very direct problem with the
move b6 however this was hard to figure
out and maybe this is where swidler
didn't assess the position correctly I
mean with hindsight you can easily say
that what I what I'm saying now
especially if you can check it with the
computer the big point is that after be
six white can take on D Phi
which is certainly a move that he did
consider I'm pretty sure um it looks
like a piece sacrifice and well what
happens if like takes yeah the point is
about Bishop f5 is also moved but the
recapture is the the really interesting
point of this if black now takes here
and we come to this position which is
quite funny white only has yeah at the
moment he's got were one point organized
62 points but black can actually take
him the the thing was to assess that
this position is actually very good for
white as like it's a completely miss
Corey miss coordinated he on this
diagonal the rook has no square it's
really am somewhat sorry side um
something like that there's even this
move you know the problem is that white
spaces are so active that black will
lose huge amounts of material the the
best defense in fact seems that after d
sexy six is not the reCAPTCHA but what
is it looks e8 is probably the the
relatively best but this also leads to a
huge initiative after Bishop before um
maybe it so that it's a calculated
something something else after after b6
I couldn't catch the press conference
would have been interesting on why he
discarded this move because if black
does not have b6 available I need to
mention one thing if black recaptures
and there's just 93 and d5 will fall
just a very bad pawn on d5 so um if b6
is not playable move or what do you play
yeah black actually then needs to
capture on your form let's say like that
and then there's 94 and get this kind of
position is certainly a bit more
comfortable for
right simply because you would have the
two bishops let's say like that you
would have the two bishops in a now
somewhat open position where black is
not easily getting play against the d4
pawn it's a it's not clear how much it
really is i mean so let's say something
like that it's not clear to me how much
it really is and black is still still
very very solidly placed but suddenly
white has has something and sooner would
if I think gladly continued this
position um maybe there was something in
his calculations would be six that
didn't really add up to him but it's
it's tricky i mean this this type of
position i can say that when i looked at
the game i immediately thought that it
takes d5 could be an idea because you
you immediately see okay black cannot
move the night you got to this brilliant
pawns and you might also go here and and
recognize that there is a bad
coordination of black's pieces but to
actually figure out that this position
is good for white is it's a different
different thing to do so it's not like
I'm saying Swilley played a very bad
game me or anything but this was
probably that the chance to take after
Queen B 1 there was 97 and now the
pressure on c5 becomes so high that you
need to exchange stuff and this is what
happened they exchanged all those on the
C file and yeah like always has this
play against a for as well so we got
those moves and here they agreed to a
draw yeah it's really a completely
completely equal position you can argue
okay white has got two bishops that's
true but this is only really important
if the structure is in a way fluid so
that it can be open can be opened and
this is
simply not the case here it's a simply
simply nothing yeah I'm a big fan of the
bishops but with this kind of dry
symmetrical position you won't get
anywhere yeah so we draw in this game
which is obviously a very good result
for slow Anand um who sort of needs to
look out for aronian one point behind in
sweida he's one and a half points behind
the swingers took place on and so he's
somewhat more dangerous than another
players as he can theoretically speaking
at least still inflict a loss to almond
and gain a point at the same time yeah
should should they have played this game
in a bit sharper manner to try to catch
the leader yeah maybe they should but
it's always hindsight is twenty-twenty
if you look at look at the ronnian game
with black against Mammadyarov where he
really yeah he'd hit the gas with black
playing this sharp sacrifice of the off
of the whole King side and said he's
setting the ball and fiery lost and
everybody afterwards the same oh why did
you play such a shabu and you know
you're out of it it's always the same
you at the end it's a success that
counts and if you are successful with
sharp stuff you did the right thing if
you if you are successful with this kind
of slow game so then then you also did
the right stuff and there will always be
people saying okay you did everything
wrong so I'm very very difficult to same
all right I hope you enjoyed the
coverage and some information about the
opening stage as well thanks for
watching